tee shirt bleu grand fausse râteaux
brouettes masque à la ceinture et
appareils de mesure de l'hydrogène
sulfuré en alerte les brigades vertes
sont en action
leur mission ramassait les sargasses sur
le littoral c'est la plage de la pointe
fola au vauclin qui est la première à
bénéficier de l'action des brigades
vertes pourrait très bien faire ça va
pour le moment on est bien l'équipe et
donc ça va vous n'avez pas de masque pas
pour le moment tant qu'on n'est pas en
présence des algues putréfiées ça va on
n'est pas encore en obligations là les
toxicos m me permettre de voir à quel
moment faut les mettre ou pas pour
évacuer la zone
on commence de 8 heures à 13 heures une
pause de 15 minutes mais ça va c'est pas
très difficile moi je trouve qu'il ya
pire que ça en fait notre plage à nous
donc il faut bien que la nettoie ses
jeunes d'horizons divers sont employés
dans le cadre de chantiers d'insertion
projet mené par l'association aux
métairies 340 personnes qui entrent aux
missions pendant six mois de nettoyer
les plages
donc on nous sommes sur la question des
plages ne sont pas dans l'eau ainsi
nettoyée les plages pour les enlever
pour enlever le tout les algues sargasse
une opération de ramassage très attendu
des vacanciers mais aussi des
commerçants qui se trouve à la pointe
fola certains restaurateurs ont dû
fermer à cause des sargasses et
concernant les activités nautiques
les loueurs ont vu leur chiffre
d'affaires diminuer aujourd'hui on a
constaté depuis la fin avril une baisse
de plus de 50% de notre chiffre
d'affaires
on a certes un resto qui ont même dû
fermer de façon provisoire parce qu'il
ne pouvait plus subvenir à leurs besoins
donc on espère rebondir trouver des
solutions est prêt pour la saison
prochaine et pas être sur une saison
catastrophique
je suis né ici je venais c'était pas
comme ça après des années ça fait 17 ans
je sais pas si je suis pas redescendue
beignets à la mer
les brigades vertes sont financés par la
ville du vauclin l'état hélas ces tirs
la contribution de la collectivité sous
ensembles et l'autre 390 millions et
pour l'opération de samatan de 50000
euros
donc ce sont des opérations nécessaires
et nous sommes certainement pas
suffisante
est-ce que des brigades vertes sont
aussi efficaces que des pelleteuses
il faut sans doute qu'il y ait des
moyens complémentaires qui ne soit pas
trop destructeur de la plage il faut
combiner les ramassage manuel avec des
engins mécaniques
lorsque c'est possible d'autres communes
comme le françois lemariey sainte-anne
devrait se voir doter de brigades vertes
les dossiers sont déjà ficelés
[Musique]